he promised a different type of politics
this government will have integrity
professionalism
and accountability at every level
but fast forward just a few months and
it's all starting to feel very familiar
your tax Affair is a distraction
the conservative party chair and former
Chancellor embroiled in a multi-million
pound tax Scandal for days the Prime
Minister dismissed calls for an inquiry
trying to turn the conversation back to
policy but today at admission there are
questions to answer I want to make sure
that we investigate them professionally
and properly and that's why I've asked
the independent advisor to conduct a
full investigation questions too though
over the prime minister's conduct what
did he know and when when I was prime
minister the advice that I received was
that there was no reason why Nadeem
zahawi could not be appointed to
government Nadim zahawi has long faced
questions over his financial affairs
have you been honest about your tax
Affairs Mr zahawi this was last summer
when he was Chancellor and running
tributory leader what's your reaction
when you saw reports that your own tax
Affairs were being investigated by your
own department so I was clearly being
smear I was being told that the serious
thought offers that the national
crimeacy that hmic are looking uh into
me I've yeah I'm not aware uh of this
but there was an investigation and Mr
zahawi has now admitted he made careless
errors and following a dispute he agreed
to making multi-million pound payment to
hmrc I think it's obvious that zaha we
can't stay as Tory party chair the very
idea that he can be discussing and
negotiating his own tax affairs with the
body that he's supposed to be running
now everybody knows it's wrong Vision
soon I promised the conservative party a
fresh start but previous administrations
are making that very difficult but it's
not just the former Chancellor that's
causing him problems it's also the man
that came before him in number 10 that
he just can't seem to shake off Boris
Johnson
after it emerged that in 2020 when he
was prime minister he was helped by his
friend Richard Sharp to secure an 800
000 pound loan just weeks later he
recommended him for BBC chair he knows
absolutely nothing about my personal
finances I can tell you that for 100
Ding Dang sure this is just another
example of the BBC disappearing up its
own fundament no longer in office still
at the center of controversy damaging
both his party and the BBC in the
process with Mr Sharp today telling
staff there will be a review into
conflicts of interest surrounding his
appointment and he regrets the
distraction this has caused
in Westminster the spotlight is on
number 10 and whether the Prime Minister
can live up to the standards he set
himself the next few weeks will
certainly put that to the test Liz Bates
Sky News Westminster